hello and welcome to the 18th PHP
tutorial in the last tutorial I showed
you guys how to make this submission box
where you could submit text and then it
would push the text up here and then we
just had submitted text and then we just
put it again down here now what we're
going to say is change text really over
time why I kind of left you guys last
time on a bit of a cliffhanger
which was me telling you that not to
leave this up on your site because I had
a caveat and that caveat is a security
risk so to show you an example of how
this can be exploited is you couldn't
put what's happening is you know in this
text box we're just echoing this text
box so you can put code into this text
box so for example we could echo strong
and hello there
submit and it actually echoes the HTML
the processed HTML now this seems you
know somewhat benign but you can start
to do other things like for example I'm
not gonna show you too much but you can
start using iframe and what I frame is
gonna do is pull up let me just show you
let's do iframe source equals H Kinsley
calm and we'll come over here and close
off the iframe so we'll submit that and
we'll wait a moment visits and as you
can see we've generated a frame that is
my website right this is my WordPress
website
now of course this is again still you
know somewhat benign but it can go
downhill pretty quick so how do we
protect against this well the popular
thing around town is the following and
it's called HTML entities so let me show
you that first so what you can do is in
the post Senate we you know we saved
this we didn't really do anything to it
but what you want to do before you start
you know outputting this and actually
doing anything with excite we're just
saying if if they posted something right
and you still didn't really save
anything like initially before we define
this stuff it didn't do anything but now
we're going to start doing stuff once we
define a variable and assign something
to it so here what most people tell you
you need to do is use HTML entities and
encase this within HTML entities so now
when we save this and let me reload to
the server let me come over here and let
me just open up a new tab real quick and
now we revisit this page and now let's
just try to put in strong and submit
that now it is it reads exactly what was
typed in right instead of actually
processing it what it ends up doing is
taking a code that looks like HTR is
HTML right like various tags and stuff
and it just converts it into string data
so that's pretty good right that's going
to protect you against somebody who's
going to use it I fringe theoretically
but is that totally protective so again
I suggest that you don't just run off I
think that you might want to check the
next video man I'm a jerk